alright this is a
level 107 pepper panic saga
walkthrough video. his is a difficult
level and i'm
sure if you're watching this video you
already know that.
if you haven't read our full pepper panic saga
level 107 guide at
pepper panic tips I suggest you do that
first so you'll understand a little bit better
the strategy involved alright so this
stuff because you have these
orange peppers that you need explode and
mister causes
turned a steal is and
it's also tough because this is such a
small
tight area in the beginning so will the
things you mention the guys
about if you get a match that would
clear to the cage the same time then you
get a quick
explosion on yours so you gonna do that
when you have a chance
and as you can see we already have Clark
the wanna borrowers peppers
now he just want to clear out the middle
so that we can set up shockwave matches
though free these
papers in the middle from the eyes we
don't have a gap set up at the moment so
we're just going to try to clear some
space as quickly as possible
you basically just wanna drop papers in
tone
get a match like this one
nor the first jury things is that
music can't get everything set up fast
enough to the you can see he's worn
he's gonna steal these papers right away
and a lot of the time whenever you
lose the orange peppers and starts to
feel like you're not going to be able to
complete a level
enormously sometimes you won't be able
to
even though he's taking our papers were
just going to continue with their plan
we got rid of the ice in the middle he's
gonna steal the last or its members on
the board cert
its its fire at this point to
arm to basically clear out the entire
board
mourner those words papers are there you
don't want to start a paper panic but
once they're gone
arm that's really the only way we can
drop new orange peppers on the board
but as you can see right now there's
known
so we were third period as fast as we
can and that'll give us the opportunity
hopefully to get some more orange
peppers and play
and you can see him on the right side
they're certain to fall in love the
we should get some more we were never
clears out completely
alright so that's a good result
those who will be overmatched these in
the bottom right hand corner
and create another explosion
answer now we just have to go back into
the middle because we still need to
free the
the papers from the cages there's no
real good moves
there that's going to set up a shock
wave so I opted to
make a big match at the bottom
drop things it looks like we're going to
have another prepare it covers all
we're gonna lose the three orange
peppers on the right side because they
were stage
to there's no real way to avoid
those like there's a tea setting up in
the middle
let's go though though the mccain we may
25 have a match and a
a panic in a row so it will be down for
a few moves
hopefully we can set up another
shockwave to shoot for the moon looks
like we can right now
pretty much worse here at the mercy
threads on the side and then we'll prob
get a shot
going down at the at the orange pepper
so that's an example of how are you can
complete the level your room whenever
the conditions are exactly
perfect arm images shows
this is an example of how you need to
adapt based on what the board here to
you
the tips in our
or forgot her ID or me if you can if you
can free up the
the papers in the middle from the ice in
the cages in the beginning in this do it
that way than that
that's that's the most common way we've
completed in the past this is another
example so I hope it will sell for
and I hope the
you complete a level soon